[Música]
gustavo petro asumió como nuevo
presidente de colombia marca el inicio
de una alternancia en el poder hacer el
primer mandatario de izquierda en ese
país suramericano
este factor es significativo si tenemos
en cuenta que colombia ha estado inmersa
en una guerra interna entre el estado y
los grupos guerrilleros que reivindican
políticamente ideas de izquierda veamos
más detalles en el siguiente informe que
preparó la redacción de france 24 sobre
la toma de posesión de gustavo petro
y prometo al pueblo
cumplir fielmente
y las leyes de colombia el centro de
bogotá se vistió de gala para recibir a
su nuevo equipo de gobierno gustavo
petro y francia- márquez la
vicepresidenta juramentaron el cargo en
una plaza de bolívar abarrotada donde se
congregaron miles de sus fieles y
personalidades políticas y diplomáticas
en su primer discurso como presidente
petro hizo alusión a su compromiso más
firme y decidido la paz la paz es el
sentido de mi vida es la esperanza de
colombia no podemos fallarle a la
sociedad colombiana
los muertos se lo merecen los vivos lo
necesitan la vida debe ser la base de la
paz una vida justa y segura una vida
para vivir sabroso para vivir feliz
para que la dicha y el progreso sean
nuestra identidad además el mandatario
mencionó asimismo su decálogo de
gobierno con un énfasis en la igualdad
con la creación de un ministerio
dedicado a ello que encabezará francia
márquez la lucha férrea contra la
corrupción o la defensa de la
biodiversidad y el medio ambiente sin
embargo la búsqueda de la llamada paz
total ocupó gran parte de su discurso y
se comprometió a seguir las
recomendaciones de la comisión de la
verdad para la implementación real y
efectiva de los acuerdos de paz tenemos
que terminar de una vez y para siempre
con seis décadas de violencia y
conflicto armado
yo diría con dos siglos de guerra
permanente la guerra eterna la guerra
perpetua de colombia se puede
cumpliremos el acuerdo de paz por
delante cuatro años donde las
negociaciones y las políticas de
sometimiento con los grupos armados
ilegales la reforma tributaria o la
lucha contra la emergencia climática
serán asimismo grandes retos a llevar a
cabo por el primer presidente de
izquierda en la historia de colombia
ya lo ven ustedes los retos el de
gustavo petro son múltiples colombia es
un país muy complejo que no atraviesa
por un buen momento económico tiene una
enorme deuda y es esa plena
implementación del acuerdo de paz y
también tiene pendiente volver a tener
visibilidad a nivel internacional hay
retos sociales hay retos educativos en
innovación en medioambiente en seguridad
y en agricultura las expectativas que
tienen los colombianos frente a lo que
será este gobierno de izquierda y
también lo que significa para la
izquierda latinoamericana son muchísimas
las expectativas que hay por eso hoy en
el debate de france 24 nos preguntamos
si también les preguntamos a ustedes a
través de las redes sociales
gustavo petro logrará el cambio en
colombia para analizar este tema
saludamos entonces a vanessa quintero
ríos ella es politóloga y también es
directora del programa de ciencias
políticas de la uned y también nos
acompaña en el estudio juan david
cárdenas él es profesor asociado e
investigador de la facultad de
comunicación de la universidad de la
sabana en colombia les recuerdo que
ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación pueden dejar todas sus
preguntas y todos sus comentarios a
través de las redes sociales estamos en
twitter en instagram en facebook en
donde no se encuentran como france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal les
recuerdo la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 también a través de
youtube pueden seguir nuestra señal en
streaming y aprovecho para saludar a las
personas que nos están escuchando a
través de nuestro podcast los invito
para que escuchen todos los contenidos
de nuestro programa que ya están
disponibles a través de app el podcast
en spotify deezer y que un min
muy bien pues entonces le doy la
bienvenida a vanessa gracias por
acompañarnos hoy aquí en el estudio de
france24 vanessa la pregunta que siempre
pongo sobre la mesa es el punto de
partida para conocer opiniones sobre
sobre el tema que vamos a analizar y
retoma entonces la pregunta que le
hacían los televidentes podrá entonces
gustavo petro lograr ese cambio tan
esperado en colombia yo creo que estamos
hablando del inicio de un cambio en los
4 años de gobierno que se van a tener
vas a ganar algunos inicios del cambio
se van a dar algunas propuestas que van
a servir justamente para las
transiciones que se buscan y las
expectativas también deben estar en ese
campo en algunos cambios en algunas
partes en otras si se van a proponer
algo digamos como que más fuerte más
puntual como se puede ver el día de hoy
con el tema de la reforma tributaria que
ya se puso en el congreso y juan david
también le doy la bienvenida gracias por
estar con nosotros en el programa punto
de partida cree usted que gustavo petro
a ser el gestor de ese cambio en
colombia y le extiendo la pregunta el
decálogo que dio a conocer en su
discurso de posesión puntos muy
importantes allí que puede destacar
bueno coincidió con vanessa en que
estamos entrando a un terreno de cambio
es muy difícil saber a ciencia cierta
hoy que puede pasar en cuatro años pero
yo por lo menos y evidenció un cambio en
el sentido de lo político en términos de
quienes hacen parte del de lo público
por ejemplo lo que se vivió en la plaza
de bolívar ayer fue
emocionante emotivo e independiente de
lo de lo que no piense de petro de lo
que no piense los actores sociales o
políticos en colombia ver la plaza
bolívar diana de personas diferentes a
las que históricamente van a este tipo
de escenarios sin marca un derrotero un
poco en cómo se va a dar la política y
quiénes van a tener de pronto un peso
mayor o un espacio mayor para esta
participación también coincido con con
vanessa en que ya empezamos a ver
ciertas puntadas en términos de que creo
que no van a esperar mucho tiempo para
empezar a soltar todas las reformas que
son unas bastante polémicas que
necesitan mucha ambientación política
mucha deliberación mucha negociación en
el escenario no sólo en el parlamento y
me parece importante la parte final de
la pregunta porque en esto se encuentra
un punto que es positivo y es que fue un
discurso muy cargado de valores y de
principios creo que el haber terminado
con un decálogo es de alguna manera
sellar un compromiso de esta muy básico
del como él piensa gobernar y como se
piensa relacionar con la sociedad yo eso
lo veo como algo positivo por lo menos
para tener un referente en términos de
cómo hacerle el control político durante
estos cuatro años si fue es fácil para
los colombianos para las personas que
ven ese discurso entender cuál es esa
estructura de los temas que quiera
abordar a través de ese decálogo y tiene
que llevar a cabo esta reforma rápido
aprovechando esa luna de miel que hay
entre la ciudadanía y el gobierno que
hay mucha expectativa y hay un ambiente
a favor de este inicio de gobierno
vanessa antes de hablar de la coyuntura
colombiana y lo que significa
la situación en la que está el país para
este gobierno que llega hablemos del
personaje de gustavo petro de lo que
significa el para la política colombiana
en donde se ha fogueado en múltiples
cargos pero también su pasado dentro de
la guerrilla del m-19 para ponerlo en
contexto para la ciudad para los
televidentes fuera de las fronteras de
colombia
la importancia de gustavo petro está
también en su participación en el m-19
en haber hecho parte como tal de esta
guerrilla que inició un proceso de paz
que fue una guerrilla que tuvo como tal
unas acciones que fueron valoradas por
sobre todo las las personas en bogotá en
las personas de las ciudades y que fue
una guerrilla que se mostró como un
ejemplo en varios aspectos como en haber
entregado las armas de la manera como lo
hizo y como incursionó a la vida
política del país si acá hay unos
aspectos importantes en donde también se
resaltan aspectos negativos obviamente
de la guerrilla y frente a este sesgo
que hay sobre este personaje como un
guerrillero entonces la llegada de un
guerrillero de una persona que estuvo
como tal en algún momento en un grupo
armado que nosotros durante años hemos
estado en esta guerra en este conflicto
pero que sea un acuerdo de paz y que
este acuerdo de paz es el que abre las
puertas para que las personas que están
en los diferentes bandos que estuvieron
como tal
en estos grupos puedan tener la
participación política que era con por
la que estaban luchando pues se vuelve
en algo fundamental en nuestra historia
y también como un aspecto importante de
decir el acuerdo de paz funciona el
acuerdo de paz logró esto y además una
condensación de las luchas sociales que
no puede dejar de lado porque la figura
de petro también es la figura de francia
y dentro de estas mismas palabras que
estuvieron ahí dentro de las mismas
consignas dentro de la política del amor
dentro del vivir sabroso vemos son los
movimientos sociales que encontraron acá
un espacio para ser visibles también
cuando había algo que añadir y le
pregunto también por la experiencia
política que tiene gustavo petro a
diferencia del saliente hoy a hoy ex
presidente duque es una figura muy
fogueada en diferentes escenarios conoce
a la perfección el funcionamiento del
estado no va a estar en un año de
aprendizaje como titulaba en algunos
medios colombianos en su momento cuando
llegó duque al poder y fuera de eso es
una figura también internacionalmente
conocida en algunos sectores políticos
por países vecinos y en diferentes
sectores a nivel mundial claro es bien
importante reconocer la trayectoria de
gustavo petro con su experiencia en el
legislativo de mucho tiempo su
experiencia bastante agridulce en el
ejecutivo en bogotá de la que estoy
seguro aprendido mucho y por eso vemos
en oye un político mucho más pragmático
ideológicamente mucho más estratégico
los nombramientos de los ministros son
claramente un ajedrez en algunos casos
en otros parecen no tener un sentido un
criterio como muy establecido pero sí es
importante reconocer en él un político
creo yo de un perfil distinto y con una
trayectoria y un carácter histórico
diferente como lo mencionaba vanessa
creo que el condensa también una
historia de lucha y una especie ejemplo
de reivindicación de una transición a la
democracia porque es casi que el ejemplo
contrario a todos los discursos que
dicen que la guerrilla se toma el poder
que la toma violenta él y su movimiento
dieron el paso contrario que fue volver
a la democracia durante más de 30 años
tratar de llegar al poder y logró
construir una historia política que lo
llevó hoy en día
también valoro lo que hice a vanessa a
poder rescatar esas expresiones que
históricamente habían estado como detrás
de esa materia opinión de la exclusión y
que hoy en día ven con bastante júbilo y
con bastante entusiasmo una persona que
por primera vez load lo representa creo
yo que muchos colombianos se despertaron
diciendo como por primera vez gane una
elección por primera vez me dio
representado y creo que eso es positivo
y es importante y lo segundo que me
llama la atención también un poco ya
como la puesta en escena y todo lo que
ocurrió ayer es como petro puede surgir
también como un líder regional que pueda
llegar a de alguna manera a rescatar
distintas iniciativas de integración que
está naufragando por falta de liderazgo
y por falta de consenso ayer estuvieron
sentados el presidente ecuador que es de
derecha el presidente de chile que y de
izquierda el rey de españa que ni
siquiera hace parte como el ámbito
político y creo que todos ven en él una
figura que seguramente despertará sus
reservas pero también tiene el potencial
político y diplomático para volver a
construir por lo menos un punto de
partida para la integración regional ese
tema del liderazgo de colombia a nivel
internacional y del liderazgo de petro a
nivel regional oa tocar más adelante
quiero preguntarles cuántas ronda a la
inversa a vanessa ya le doy la palabra
sobre lo importante
de esta llegada de petro al poder en
cuanto a la desmitificación de la
izquierda en colombia que siempre se vio
como una izquierda de lucha armada de
guerrilleros en las selvas luchando
contra el estado ahora tenemos en
colombia un ejecutivo que viene también
de esas filas ya explicaban ustedes el
pasado que tiene el presidente petro qué
significa esto para la historia política
y la construcción democrática de
colombia pues para la historia política
del país creo yo que es un punto de
inflexión es bastante importante y
considerable que por primera vez la
izquierda llegue al poder en colombia y
sobre todo empiece también a tener este
tránsito que implica y seguramente va a
tener muchos obstáculos muchas caídas y
muchos problemas de insertarse en la
lógica desde la burocracia estatal de la
toma de decisiones de los procesos de
políticas públicas porque una cosa es de
estar del lado de quien demanda del lado
de quien reclama del lado quien protesta
y exige todo el tiempo y otra cosa es
estar ya en una situación como usted lo
mencionaba al inicio con una deuda
pública enorme
coloquialmente con una olla raspada y
con una situación internacional que es
bastante compleja no sólo para
colombiano para todos los países del
mundo en términos de
desabastecimiento alimenticio la escasez
de recursos natural y la inflación creo
que históricamente es muy importante que
llegue pero también coincide con un
momento muy complicado y seguramente va
a tener muchos problemas que veremos
cómo va a lograr solventar ya teniendo
claro este contexto en está entendiendo
ya quién es el personaje lo que implica
esto para la política colombiana
hablemos de la gobernabilidad el logro
llegar con un buen respaldo en el
parlamento eso le da ciertas garantías a
la hora de gobernar pero qué tan fuerte
son estas coaliciones que logró armar
todas estas alianzas que se armaron en
esas elecciones parlamentarias de cara a
este gobierno que está empezando como lo
ve usted que análisis puede hacer de eso
bueno lo primero es que hay unas
reformas que le está planteando que son
justas y necesarias en esta época para
el contexto del país y para contexto de
mundo entonces digamos como que esa
reforma sí o sí son reformas que se
deben hacer que están ahí y que son
necesarias no he dicho digamos como
desde una tendencia política en general
sino desde hacia donde debemos avanzar
como sociedad y aquí la cuestión e el
debate va a ser como las fuerzas
políticas van a entrar y van a mediar en
algunos campos o en otros o qué tan
fuertes que tan radicales van a ser
estas reformas
yo creo que llega con todo su movimiento
al pacto histórico de una manera muy
fuerte con unas alianzas importantes con
el partido verde con otros partidos que
se vienen sumando incluso con unas
alianzas con otros políticos que le van
a permitir
transitar en un primer momento hacia
esas reformas de una manera importante y
sustancial creo que
en este primer momento vamos a tener
esto de una manera más más más fuerte
más concreta pero no podemos digamos que
decir que esto va a estar de una manera
perpetua sino que a partir de la
radicalidad y de los debates que se
vayan a hacer y de los elementos que se
van a ir ingresando en el marco de los
debates que van a entrar artículos que
van a decir no así sí pero no pues ahí
es donde nos vamos a dar cuenta dónde
vamos a tener estos aspectos la hora
ahora la oposición está con el centro
democrático pero en general los partidos
tradicionales están ahí jugando a estar
en a favor de estas reformas también
entra en juego la capacidad de acción
que es una factura que tiene pendiente
de mostrar después de la alcaldía de
bogotá donde se le criticó mucho no
tener capacidad de actuar rápidamente
algo para complementar cuánta vez sobre
este tema de la gobernabilidad mencionar
que quizás y como suele pasar al inicio
todos los gobiernos llegan con unas
coaliciones que en aparenten
aparentemente fuertes porque creo que
son coaliciones que en este caso están
muy ancladas en
en lo burocrático en el haber dado tanto
ciertos ministerios o ciertos cargos de
representación a los distintos partidos
que lo están acompañando pero coincido
con vanessa que cuando lleguen los temas
más espinosos pensional salud tributario
educativo claramente liberalismo el
conservatismo están en orillas distintas
el partido verde a veces tiene ciertas
diferencias en términos de no sé desde
la de la corrupción de la transparencia
un poco de lo procedimental de lo
democrático y seguramente llegarán
momentos donde esa coalición se va a
romper o se va a fragmentar y va a tener
que entrar a operar nuevamente el
aparato burocrático del estado y creo
que por eso el nombra muy hábilmente
querámoslo novarro y barreras como como
presidente del congreso se conoce todos
los procedimientos todas las maneras
buenas malas formales informales de
poder adelantar en todos estos procesos
y tiene también su equipo y se la está
jugando y y apostó por por un cambio yo
creo que rápido lo más rápido posible
para que la coalición no se fragmenta
pero seguramente cuando la reforma te
empiezan a impactar a ciertos sectores a
tocar ciertos intereses pues claramente
estas colisiones van a la fragmentación
y vuelve y queda otra vez
como un escenario apto para el demostrar
su capacidad de negociación si esto fue
una suerte simplemente porque empezará
al gobierno si de verdad es una persona
capaz de generar consensos dentro de las
coaliciones en paso a tratar el tema de
la paz no voy a profundizar mucho acá
porque hace unos días hicimos todo un
programa completo en cuanto a esa
propuesta de paz total que propone el
presidente petro pero quiero entonces
abordar un tema puntual y es una posible
mesa de negociación con él ln que es una
guerrilla muy distinta a lo que en
términos estructurales y la comparamos
con la antigua guerrilla de las farc y
los grupos delincuenciales también
difícil ver como puede ser un
acercamiento o una negociación con ellos
vanessa impresiones sobre este tema
es muy complejo la verdad digamos que el
tema con el ln es la forma como ellos
están organizados y esa organización
como hace que sus debates realmente sean
traspasados a la ciudadanía lo que le l
m quiere es que la ciudadanía sea
también la que haga parte de los
diálogos esto es un un reto enorme para
nosotros pero creo que acá puede haber
una disposición d
sentarse hablar algunos puntos dado que
es con petro entonces acá hay una
seguridad es eso le da seguridad al ln y
hay otro punto que es diferente que es
todo esto que se ha dado con el clan del
golfo porque es que no pueden tener la
misma connotación que tienen los grupos
guerrilleros un tour por y eso va a ser
un llamado a un tipo de negociación
diferente y acá lo que tenemos es un
ministro de defensa que va a ser muy muy
importante para poder llevar a cabo esta
este diálogo
efectivamente con el clan del golfo
cuando a versión impresión yo veo que
dice abrir lo que se llama una
estructura de oportunidad política para
todos a lee le encuentra un gobierno que
va a ser receptivo de sus de sus
intenciones de sentarse a negociar
estos grupos armados organizados
destrucción del golfo ya decretos y no
estoy mal un cese unilateral porque se
da cuenta que es un momento también
estratégico donde puede pronto negociar
su sometimiento en los mejores términos
aprovecha de ganar algo de la euforia y
un poco el entusiasmo del clima de
opinión y el gobierno también entiende y
yo lo veo en los de carlos gusta el
discurso un poco esta relación entre paz
y desarrollo alternativo y es que si se
la va a jugar por la transición
energética que implicará dejar de
recibir muchos recursos del petróleo y
de la extracción minera se las está
jugando por la industria y sobre todo
por el turismo y para que pueda haber
desarrollo turístico tiene que haber lo
que él llama la paz total entonces creo
que es un juego donde todos pueden ganar
algo y si sale bien nos va a ir bien a
todos pero claramente pues todos tienen
sus las intereses ahí en juego cuando
uno de los titulares en la prensa
internacional un día después de la
posesión de petro es esa declaración que
dio durante el discurso sobre la lucha
antidrogas la lucha contra las drogas
fracasó así lo calificó a gustavo petro
en su discurso que se puede hablar de
este tema esto genera también una
necesidad de tener un diálogo fluido con
eeuu sobre este tema y sobre también los
países vecinos que se han visto
afectados precisamente porque estos
grupos delincuenciales ya se han
convertido en grupos transnacionales y
vemos a ecuador o costa rica-méxico que
están inmersos en todas estas cadenas
del narcotráfico que se puede decir
sobre este punto como puede que puede
ofrecer petropar esta lucha yo hay lo
primero que identificó incluso lo lleva
más allá del tema de las drogas también
lo lleva el tema el medio ambiente es un
poco este principio de la
corresponsabilidad
y es que no tiene que recaer sobre
colombia y mucho menos de la manera como
viene siendo es que exponiendo los
muertos y llevándose como la parte
negativa de de toda esa situación y el
llamar un poco a los países que son los
consumidores a que también tomen cartas
en el asunto pero claramente desde que
fue senador de la república en todas sus
declaraciones se ha puesto por ejemplo
las fumigaciones ha optado por la
sustitución manual y voluntaria de
cultivos ilícitos e incluso que estoy
seguro que es un partidario total de la
legalización y abrir el mercado de la
droga incluso no estaría yo tan lejos de
pensar que eso es un mercado público
manejado por el estado para romper con
ese monopolio de estas economías
criminales y claramente para que esto se
pueda dar tiene que tener un buen
diálogo con eeuu que por lo menos en
estos meses desde su elección hasta hoy
ha sido mucho más fluido que lo que fue
en cuatro años con iván duque entonces
no sé eso en que pueda parar pero por lo
menos los primeros pasos son muy firmes
de lo que estábamos viviendo en colombia
hay una oportunidad que vanessa para que
colombia se vuelva un país abanderado de
una nueva estrategia de la lucha contra
las drogas y este factor que menciona a
juan david de una posible legalización
que el estado maneje este producto
mercado como se le quiera
nombrar puede ser una oportunidad para
el país esto puede ser una oportunidad
también para mostrarle a washington las
cosas se pueden hacer distintos no
poniendo muertos no reforzando el
ejército sino yendo por otro camino acá
volvemos con el tema de que se vuelve
una bandera que no es solamente de petro
esto es un debate que están dando muchos
países en este momento incluso hay
muchos estados y sobre todo europeos que
ya han pasado como por por pensarse el
tema de la drogas de lo preventivo no
solamente es el tema de los cultivos es
el tema de como nosotros estamos
generando procesos de prevención y cómo
a partir de esto incluso podemos llevar
a las personas a la rehabilitación o
incluso recuerdo el tema de las jeringas
a ahora que me acuerdo cómo hacer que el
tema de las drogas en su prevención
también de otras enfermedades como
podría ser el vih yo creo que colombia
acá puede ser un abanderado porque hemos
sido grandes
golpeados de toda esta lucha contra las
drogas también en américa latina'
tendríamos una forma de de unidos que
también es un llamado a la unidad de
cómo américa latina' lograr estar en el
centro del debate el problema que tiene
méxico también con esto bolivia también
acá tiene un debate muy fuerte entonces
creo que es de américa latina podemos
abanderar nos en esta lucha hacia el
mundo y que seamos nosotros también en
escenarios internacionales los que
unidos que era también el llamado
llamado la unidad para poder que estos
debate realmente tengan un impacto en
los espacios de toma de decisión mundial
hoy pasando ya la segunda mitad del
programa usted menciona la parte
internacional en la unión con otros
países de la región pasó entonces al
tema de las relaciones internacionales
vemos a un presidente petro con una
relación fluida con eeuu usted lo
mencionaba juan david también es una
necesidad de restablecer el diálogo con
caracas sobre todo por la actividad de
la frontera y por la cantidad de
colombianos y venezolanos que viven a un
lado o al otro de la frontera tema
internacional juan david puntos claves
cuál es la prioridad a cada relación con
eeuu liderazgo regional como lo ve usted
yo creo que más que liderazgo regional
es el rescatar el sentido de lo regional
puede que él termine siendo la cabeza de
esa como esa nueva estructura de
integración regional pero si veo un
movimiento muy fuerte incluso de un
nuevo liderazgo de izquierda diferentes
a los anteriores yo creo que la
caricatura perfecta fue ver a bórico
aplaudido y casi que amado por la
multitud y alberto fernández dormido en
la segunda fila como en el trasfondo
creo que ven una nueva generación que
está pensando la región de una manera
muy diferente y que entiende que para
poder ser exitosos de alguna forma
tienen que unirse pero unirse en un buen
sentido no unirse en el sentido
histórico en que vienen de alguna manera
trabajando y qué
la evidencia está clara que no ha
funcionado de la mejor forma
entonces yo sigo en petro un interés por
rescatar el sentido de la integración
regional no sé si le interese ser él
quien encabece o el abanderado pero
claramente sabe que en el mundo de hoy
es fundamental la integración no en vano
también lo menciona roy barreras creo
que es un poco ya exaltado menciona una
moneda única
latinoamericana y volver a pensar
seguramente como en estos grandes
acuerdos pero es que ahorita no hay nada
de acuerdo a los presidentes cambian los
acuerdos entonces el grupo de lima
cuando estamos de derecha el mercosur
cuando somos de la izquierda pero no hay
un organismo que seguramente en algún
momento lo fue la oea cuando significaba
algo pero hoy en día no lo hay y un
ejemplo de fracaso digámoslo así de
unasur que se mueve no solamente nada
vanessa hablando de esa integración de
izquierda pero escribe uno unas
izquierdas muy raras en este momento la
coyuntura latinoamericana ve uno una
izquierda como la de daniel ortega
completamente
dictatorial rígida con los medios de
comunicación persiguiendo a la iglesia
bueno lo mismo cuba
vemos venezuela como en un limbo que no
se sabe qué rumbo tener en este momento
y chile colombia y no sabemos que pueda
liderar brasil después de las elecciones
se puede articular esa izquierda tan
extraño que estamos viendo ahora yo creo
que hay unos cambios que mencionaban que
son importantes y es diferenciar las
izquierdas esa izquierda tradicional que
veníamos nosotros durante toda la guerra
de guerrillas durante todas estas
todas estas formas como la izquierda se
posicionó en américa latina y ahora que
es una izquierda un poco diferente un
poco mal socialdemócrata si estamos
haciendo una izquierda socialdemócrata
que está buscando los cambios pero es a
partir de unos cambios en nuestra
información es dentro del estado de una
manera democrática fundamental es una
lucha también
feminista acá muy fuerte porque el
género ahora es una parte importante del
debate el hecho de que petro también
tenga esta alianza con boris que se fue
incluso para chile durante su campaña es
porque también el tema de género se
volvió un tema crucial las mujeres
también fuimos las que estuvimos
apoyando acá estas luchas y somos ahí
digamos como que fundamentales en estas
transformaciones que es acá hay unos
aspectos que para nosotros también se
van a volver
fundamentales y que también genera una
transformación de esas izquierdas y esos
pensamientos políticos que ahora van a
primar si puede haber diálogo claro que
pueda haber diálogo pero el diálogo se
va a ser a partir de estos nuevos
principios si yo no ve la importancia
que tiene la mujer latinoamericana
porque está en uno de sus puntos del
decálogo la protección y la voz de las
mujeres en wanda bill le pregunto por
venezuela nada relación complicada que
lleva en bogotá y caracas a lo largo de
los años aquí hay una oportunidad
entonces para petro ser de pronto un
interlocutor con washington que también
se está tratando de abrir a venezuela
por la necesidad de tener más petróleo a
raíz de la guerra de ucrania yo
inicialmente un primer paso que se va a
dar y que creo que no va a demorar mucho
que es el tema del restablecimiento de
las relaciones comerciales creo que eso
es esencial
urgente y va a beneficiar a muchas
personas
el segundo escenario si lo ve un poco
más complejo porque involucra ya los
aspectos geopolíticos que escapan a
digamos a la autoridad o al ámbito de lo
que petro pueda o no pueda llegar a ser
que puede ser petro posiblemente un poco
en lo que mencionaban esa quizás un
punto de unión entre entre la vieja
izquierda y la nueva izquierda en
términos de la democratización de los
debates que encierran todas las
dinámicas de la izquierda pero
mencionado venezuela nicaragua cuba son
izquierdas que si bien llegan al poder a
través de procesos electorales que todos
sabemos cómo se terminan de cantando
dejaron a la democracia como un aspecto
secundario o discursivo o simplemente
retórico mientras que vemos como
izquierdas como la de bórico la de petro
en el mismo luis arce en bolivia son
izquierdas que a pesar de las
dificultades llegan al poder por la vía
electoral entonces creo no sé si puede
llegar a ser un puente entre eeuu o
venezuela pero sí puede que sea un
puente para que fluya un diálogo
político entre la oposición y
algo y el oficialismo en venezuela
porque por lo menos los debates se
vuelvan a dar en términos de la
discusión
rescatar la democracia
entendida en términos reales en países
como venezuela como nicaragua en donde
quizás el ti tiene una confianza de sus
mandatarios pero a la vez tiene también
todos los ojos puestos encima porque en
colombia nadie le va a permitir que
restablezca relaciones políticas con
maduro como si fueran los mejores amigos
de un día para otro entonces yo veo como
este doble escenario y si es un
escenario complejo ya entró en la recta
final del programa quiero preguntarles
por el tema económico colombia recibe
este nuevo gobierno con un déficit
presupuestario complejo con unas arcas
como lo decía wanda después bastante
raspadas después de la pandemia el
gobierno del presidente eduqué pero
también con una propuesta de dejar esa
dependencia del petróleo y apostarle a
nuevas formas de financiación y también
invitando a los colombianos a trabajar a
producir escenario económico para esta
recta final del programa vanessa muchos
retos hay mucha informalidad en
colombia' zonas poco desarrolladas en
términos industriales o zonas demasiado
desarrolladas en términos industriales
yo creo que la figura de nuestro
ministro haciendo es fundamental
persona preparada una persona reconocida
no solamente en el ámbito académico sino
que un economista reconocido y que tiene
digamos como que todos los elementos
para que una reforma tributaria
realmente tenga la capacidad de impactar
positivamente en la en los impuestos y
en esos y supuestos que hay que
conseguir creo que acá hay un punto muy
positivo en ese aspecto hay que recordar
que también el tema de las energías
limpias él lo llama esa una transición
no es algo que se va a hacer en estos
cuatro años son procesos de transición
las exploraciones que en estos momentos
están van a continuar todos los procesos
y todos los contratos que están van a
continuar entonces vamos a tener ahí
unas partes de tranquilidad y también
vamos a tener con esta reforma
tributaria un aumento a los impuestos
justamente para el petróleo para el oro
que nos van a dar digamos que acá unos
recursos importantes para esa justicia
social que se llama petro entonces acá
hay unos aspectos fundamentales e
importantes
en que la reforma tributaria que en
estos momentos se va a llevar a cabo
pues no va a golpear a los más pobres
que incluso fue el tema de las protestas
que tuvimos sino que efectivamente va
por un porcentaje de la población que
tienen los recursos para pagarlos y acá
hay algo muy importante y fuese llamado
a la solidaridad a ver que los impuestos
realmente son una forma de ayudar a los
niños a los ancianos son una forma
realmente apoyar a la sociedad y a los
que más lo necesitan entonces estos
llamados que ahorita lo lo mencionaba
juan con el tema de los valores también
pueden hacer que haya una mejor
disposición
justamente esas personas a pagar estos
tributos cuando su opinión sobre el tema
coincido con vanessa en un valor que
para mí es fundamental que es el valor
de la confianza creo que el primer paso
en la construcción de la confianza fue
el nombramiento del ministro como
ministro que nadie criticó que todavía
el nombre más recuperado y al que quizás
le podemos atribuir que el mercado del
dólar si bien fruto se haya mantenido
más o menos dentro de unas franjas
relativamente estables cuando ahorita
igual poder al otro día el dólar se fue
a las nubes digamos que por ese lado hay
una confianza de partida que es
importante yo veo como cuatro elementos
que están muy relacionados con la
reforma que van a empezar a ocurrir acá
que son por un lado la formalización
laboral la reforma laboral ya dijeron
que iban a hacer una modificación por
ejemplo los contratos de prestación de
servicios y en general una revisión de
las condiciones laborales hoy en día en
colombia eso puede tener un impacto
positivo para el trabajador pero muchos
empresarios dirán ya no va a poder
contratar levanta gente porque me
cambiaron entonces había como un primer
escenario complejo el segundo es el de
la industrialización yo lo relacionó con
un término que mencionan mucho petro y
todos sus ministros que es el de la
soberanía alimentaria y es como en pleno
siglo 21 pues creo que colombia entra
lidad como en una fase de
industrialización
que una históricamente haría eso pasó
por allá con la sal a los 60 a los 70
pero quién sabe qué pasa en ese tiempo
que echamos para atrás hoy en día no
somos capaces de producir nuestros
propios alimentos y no nos pasa sólo en
colombia pasan todo el mundo y por eso
ucrania entra en guerra y
semillas y fertilizantes no hay tres que
los países dejaron de producir las
materias primas y los insumos básicos
para la producción de alimentos está el
tema de la redistribución con la reforma
tributaria que creo que la economía va a
depender claramente de lo que pueda
ocurrir ahí porque ahí es donde ese
bolsillo básico se va a empezar a llenar
y se va a poder empezar a hacer el gasto
público y coincidió también con con el
tema de la solidaridad y yo le agregaría
un tema es el de la gestión pública y la
transparencia y sobre todo la lucha
contra la corrupción que es el que
cerraría el círculo de la confianza y es
decirle al pueblo vea recaudamos estos
impuestos pero nos están yendo por allá
a esos 70 mil que iban para el internet
al bolsillo de empresarios o esta plata
de la paz no terminó en mansiones o en
contratos de privados sino que se puede
a ver realmente que el recaudo que tiene
el gobierno se está gastando en los más
vulnerables y las personas que más lo
necesitan bueno pues ya lo vieron
ustedes los retos son múltiples en todas
las áreas en la coyuntura en colómbia es
bastante particular es un país diferente
a muchos de la región precisamente por
este tema de la paz y el antecedente que
tiene de ese conflicto interno a lo
largo de tantas décadas yo
david por habernos acompañado hoy en el
programa haber estado con nosotros para
explicarles a ustedes la audiencia de
france 24 cómo está el panorama de
colombia de cara a este nuevo gobierno
del presidente gustavo petro ustedes
pueden seguir dejando todos sus
preguntas y todos sus comentarios a
través de las redes sociales y sigan en
sintonía de france 24
[Música]